i saw an interesting tweet from michael
malus man we shot this guy out who is
michael males we should have him he's
too much he's a writer really funny guy
but it's just really good and uh
it was it was it was an ad
an idea he tweeted out and then i just
elaborate elaborated upon that
by by mere a virtue of your existence
proves that victory is not only possible
but that it's already happened before
yeah it seems like that oh and
and so so that's something
yeah and basing it off of what he was
tweeting and what i mean by that is
there's been so much evil in this world
the rise of communism the dictators the
the murderers the nazis the fascists and
here we sit today
doing a show about american values
freedom and liberty which proves not
only have we won in the past but here we
are able to continue this which means
victory is not only possible but it
already happened we constantly do things
that are challenging and hard like i i
tweeted out i think yesterday if you
only ever did what was easy for you you
just laid there you never would have
gotten you would have laid there until
you died like we always struggling to
learn how to do something new and to
change our environment that's
ultimately what we're tools for i love
this quote it's like of course the
shortcut is hard if it was easy it would
just be the way
you know what i mean so it's like
everything we're doing if we're doing
the easiest thing imaginable it's it's
it's
it's not challenging it's just the
normal
but for all of us that are fighting for
something that believe in something that
are challenging something of course it's
hard
it has to be but but
definitely possible that's the point
i'm saying yeah these things that seem
insurmountable i think it's because
we're looking at big picture a lot of
times like crt and everyone's like i
don't know where do you even be get but
when you break it down to like the local
level then you see like teachers union
or a group of teachers are revolting or
this guy's getting removed this this
teacher is getting removed for good
thing to see that that guy wearing the
sickle who's got the antifa and the
black lives matter and all that
communist stuff who says he's got 180
days to turn the kids into
revolutionaries he's getting fired
the woman that said pledge allegiance to
the queers she's getting fired pressure
okay so offensive statement it is very
offensive to everybody to everybody and
anyone and you know it look uh standing
for the pledge of allegiance in school
right now is not super cool depending on
where you live my son told me a story
about he's literally the only one in his
class who stands every morning recites
the pledge wow everyone else i was the
only kid not doing that when i was
little right because that was kind of
the cool thing to do but you know what
now the rebellious thing to do is to
stand up and say i pledge allegiance to
the flag of the united states and to the
republic for which it stands one nation
divided is it under god one nation
divided one nation united under god i
can't remember indivisible with the
weirded out by the god thing in the it
was added in the 50s
under god and on the constitution your
rights are from god i'm like that's just
why are you weirded out by it it's
literally in the declaration of
independence upon which this government
was founded because i think well we
talked about this before i wish we were
here when we had the first time that our
rights are just we just earned them
through warfare we took them by forces
no they're given to you by god that's
what they some magic thing they wrote in
there to be like and if anyone ever
messes with you just say you can never
and it's like no this didn't exist
before you created it
of american freedom we talked about this
you don't understand what right means
the government infringing upon your
rights doesn't mean you don't have
rights it means the government is
infringing upon them
yeah i i think the idea that you have a
right to anything in this reality is is
absurd
are you born with the right to defend
yourself
i mean i have i'm born with the ability
no no technically no because you're a
baby with no abilities you just label
that's an ability but not a right i have
no rights as a as a small infant you
have no right perceive yourself
nature with no government around you and
there's people there's people around you
and you're all around you does anybody
would anybody look at you and say to you
sir that you don't have the right to
defend yourself
well i mean if uh if i've done something
wrong i'm no the answer is no i think in
in a society that word right might not
even exist don't even use the word
society just imagine a bunch of dudes in
anarchy yeah they would they would
probably fight but would they look at
you and be like you have the right to
defend yourself no i don't think that
word would even enter that alexa
alexacon into a mind of barbarians
so ian if if you're staying in the
middle of the woods
and some guy runs up screaming with a
pointy stick would you just go oh well
guess i'll die i'm not saying because
these things might i'm not saying that
they they're not good things these ideas
are great all right but the fact that
they're given from god okay what was
your question again if you're standing
in middle of the woods and a guy's
running at you screaming with a stick
would you go i have no idea i would
jiu-jitsu his ass and put my knee on
you have no right to do it i got to
answer your question however i want good
you have a right to do that you have no
right to do that no neither of us have a
right we just do have a right to do that
no no i have the ability it's not a
right what is this right what does it
even mean
what what what what do you mean
you bro you're making semantic well
nothing i'm being very literal um right
legal rights no we're not talking about
legal rights we're talking about natural
rights natural rights natural like in
other countries they aren't natural
that's the point well it's because
they're also not monotheistic some of
their pagans some of them are different
but that doesn't mean they're wrong it
just means it's a different view of what
is natural
in order to live
you must defend yourself
if you can't live
then you don't exist
you have a right
to defend yourself
that's the first most fundamental right
that you have a right is a legal social
or ethical principle of freedom or
entitlement ethical rights are
fundamental normative rules about what
is allowed of people or owed to people
according to some legal system social
convention or ethical theory rights are
of essential importance in such
disciplines as law and ethics especially
theories of justice and deontology
they're different everywhere
every country is different every ethic
or
which is that monotheistic gods gave us
natural law and natural rights which
gave us the united states of america
that's why it's not universally
applicable because there's other
countries around the world and other
places other people that don't have the
same perception of god and it's it's
it's really simple again ian you're
confusing infringement with existence of
rights
you plea clarify that please you're
arguing that because someone with power
would suppress your rights your rights
don't exist that's not true
no no
if you're if you are captured in war
yeah okay you can physically defend
yourself from your capture captors even
though they will beat you and try and
stop you and they will take they will
tie your hands behind your back and
continue beating you and you can still
resist
you have a right no you have the ability
to do it doesn't give you the right that
doesn't exist in a pow camp yes
literally there are no rights in a pow
camp yes there are you're just there you
don't understand what a right is you're
confusing and if you're like you're
violating my human right my basic
they're like what who is this what is
this thing and they're beating you so
again you're talking about the
infringement of rights versus the
existence they don't understand that
person doesn't doesn't it doesn't exist
to them so it's like for you to say
because i believe it it it's real for
you even though you don't understand now
if you attack the the the the soldier
keeping you there will he defend himself
likely but he has no right to do that no
but he has the ability to and probably
should preserve his own skin
of course he has the right to defend
himself he has the uh i mean okay now
we're just talking about rights and
abilities i'm talking rights are legal
things and you do this all the time you
make some answers you just said that
rights are legal things no natural
natural legal social or ethical
assessment natural rights come from
natural law which comes from god and you
do this a lot when you lose an argument
you make a semantic change to the i
don't think there's going to be a winner
or loser to this we're just talking
about it but rights literally do exist
there's like the golden rule and there's
there's certain rules that transcend all
civilizations
the golden rule only works in certain
types of civilizations like
it doesn't work if everyone's cheating
so there are bad people there are good
people they're an infringement
infringement of rights and rights exist
regardless of whether someone tries to
suppress them i don't i don't agree with
that i think that rights only exist
because we tell ourselves they exist
so even if you actually have a point but
i wanted to read to you a little bit
about natural law because natural law is
an idea in sorry it's a theory in ethics
and philosophy that says that human
beings possess intrinsic values that
govern our reasoning and behavior and
this is something that is understood to
exist in almost every single human
civilization these are overarching ideas
this is like the understanding that
murder is wrong it's like the
understanding that marriage is a
societal good not true in every society
but commonly understood in most of them
so this ties directly into the idea of
rights as being something understood
governed by natural law so you should
look at like natural rights as they grow
out of natural law it's something that
is over most society not strictly uh
like we use in our judeo-christian
society here i think i think jack
i think jack put it well about
what you need to be able to do in order
to survive and function which is a
natural natural right they've
essentially codified that into a
structure a lot of kind of ten
commandments is what he was doing like
these if you follow these you'll
probably survive for a long time and so
will will our species and so then the
americans were like okay let's make a
government out of that and tell everyone
these are like uncorruptable parts of
you and that's if we believe that then
they become on it
but only because the government by gun
forces is commanding that is that able
to exist if you're in the middle of the
woods and you're buck naked you can
speak freely you can move freely you can
defend yourself no one can stop you yeah
but there's no law though there's
nothing that there's no rights in this
bro the law is to restrict the
government not people how many times we
have to say that you mean the bill of
rights are the constitution but all the
laws in america is to restrict well yes
the bill of rights the constitution the
idea of natural law whatever this is to
restrict the government
from infringing upon the rights that you
have innately that's what they tell you
that's my my argument is that i don't
think innate i don't think people
innately have any right to anything we
just we were fortunate to be born into a
society where we so you know total will
to power god i mean if you were thrown
if we were thrown into the jungle alone
naked
what the hell there is no natural right
it is what are you talking about we just
survived
yeah so you can defend yourself from
predators you can say well not because i
have a right to it it's because what the
hell i'm doing it like in order to exist
as a human being you have to defend
yourself
yeah that's for real so ian that's what
we're talking about if you talk about
laws if you don't think the right exists
that means you would just lay down
whenever threatened no
the law calling it a law and saying it's
like what's that
you just said if you don't think the law
exists i'm sorry if you if you don't
think rights exist then you would just
lay down and die whenever you're
attacked by a predator saying that
defending yourself
the act of writing yourself means that
you enacted a right i think is is
fallacy just because you defend yourself
doesn't mean you're enacting any kind of
human rights
yeah just because you're literally
exercising you're right when you defend
yourself no you're exerci you're
defending yourself you're not i mean in
the united states you would be
exercising in a country where you're not
allowed to defend yourself like north
korea we're done because you're just
arguing semantics well we have yet to
begin tim because in north korea you
don't have the right to defend yourself
against the north korean guy they just
beat you and infringe on your right
there's no rights there they don't have
rights you don't have human rights so
this is what they're saying when they
say that the rights are given by god
this means that the government should
not ever infringe your right to defend
yourself ever ever ever this is what the
founding fathers has done the
constitution says the government can't
do that
but other governments do that yeah but a
human being in any circumstance when
threatened has the right to defend
itself as does every other creature on
the planet when threatened just because
a bear can hold down the fox and the fox
is struggling doesn't mean the fox
doesn't have the right to defend itself
it doesn't have the right
you don't know what the words mean
let's just go to super chat because
maybe i don't
you because we defined it first time
long time listener first time caller
here's ten dollars can i have your
attention are you telling me god gave
you the power
yes you're saying god gave you the power
jack are you going to defend yourself
ian yeah you think god did that there
are there are fundamental base truths
that we understand very simply and what
i mean is obviously we can get into the
nuance and complexities of how glass
shatters but typically when you throw a
rock in a window it breaks there's
nuance there i understand that typically
a bear when hungry will eat something to
to feed itself there are basic things we
understand to be true
there there are rules as to how they
define what life is and there are basic
functions as to how that life
propagates in fact there are some plants
that defend themselves because if you
have no right to self-defense meaning a
fundamental
entitlement
to your ability to stay alive then you
would cease to exist because your
lineage your dna would just collapse
meaning everything that exists today
exists because it had a right to
survival no that's not what we didn't
have rights before you know we invented
them things things survived and
propagated because you're talking about
paramecium's in the tide pool they
didn't have rights they didn't have a
basic paramecium rights they just
survived the ones that ate the food
survived and the ones that didn't didn't
so the point is arising from the fact
that everything that survived fought for
survival we recognize a fundamental
naturally occurring entitlement existing
within life forms to try to stay alive
right now circuit is a natural
entitlement to try to survive this is
what you do what are you talking about a
natural entitlement to try to survive no
you haven't because you don't know what
the word you have to try to survive
you're not entitled to it because you
just see some things never change around
here
ian we're gonna go to super chats yes we
are but if you can't agree on a
definition of a word that's even right
we can't agree on the definition we
gotta agree on because you're making it
up and i just read it to you well you
just gave me like a long three-part
definition firstly because
if you're not smart enough to know words
and i can't even read you the definition
how do we have a conversation look
everybody firstly everybody can make
mistakes you made a mistake earlier when
you you said a word that wasn't the
right word um and we're not we haven't
even yet to agree let i'm gonna end this
conversation very simply
jack and i say here's a right you say
rights don't exist i say okay ian let's
try and figure stop okay let's try and
figure out what rights means here's the
definition of a right and you say well
that's wrong and i refuse to accept okay
you don't want to be that's not what
happened and you you just told me the
definition
of rights don't exist
i said that the idea that god gives you
basic intrinsic rights is idiot it's
it's fantasy and that's why people are
erupting against it right now because
you don't know what the word means
all right it's a it's a fundamental
natural natural rights a fundamental
naturally occurring entitlement
intrinsic within life this is something
you just create this is literally just
read it too but you just said that it
had to do with ethics and some he was
supposed to ethics
it said rights exist very prominently
within legal and ethical theories
another one ethical social issues and
legal theories i think
this is some of the best whiskey i have
ever had
can i put
look at this this rice ohichi rice
whiskey this is some of the best stuff
i've ever had thank you so much i
appreciate that thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you